I know you're all leaving in an hour but
until that time you're under my command
and as leader it is my job to make my
employees lives better so what can I do
for you
Gina I would like to answer the phone
always just like uh-huh
done Charles lift the precinct wide ban
a missing word succulent done I want to
work in the break room son off to hear
Charles say succulent dun dun dun Zell
Washington if she's working in the break
room can I move my nap couch out into
the bullpen Brooks & Dunn oh so your
plan is to not take us seriously at all
oh I am as serious as a heart attack
no offense Scully yeah mine are never
that serious I call it whoopsies Scully
where are you on digitizing the old Case
Files as of yesterday I'm officially 1%
done why are you smiling
that's nothing boy there's thousands of
cases and for each one I have to fill
out 200 little box thingies on 50
different screens at least you get to
sit on your butt all day that's actually
the worst part my doctor said I have an
anal Canyon Scully why are you always
telling us about your disgusting body I
don't see anything that's because it's
all bored okay yes
Terry is having another kid we are
pregnant but that's a secret it's way
too soon to tell anyone
I only stumbled across because I'm such
an amazing detective who accidentally
hit reply all like some idiot on a
brunch thread yeah that but look Terry
can't know the secret is out you got the
email to boo crap you're right all right
we just have to break into his email
account delete the message while he's
down at the gym great all right here's
the plan I'll go down what are you gonna
do Jake I'm obviously about to say okay
I'll go get I thought it was a call
response it's not okay I'll go down
there dude okay here's the plan
I'll go down to the gym and have Terry
take me through his work out you guys
get savant from IT to help you hack into
his account if anything goes wrong
Scully faked a heart attack so what do
you think in classic angina or something
sexier like myocardial infarction just
drop down onto the ground and wiggle I'm
gonna nail this I'm in what are your
demands
I guarantee that this drill doesn't end
until one of us is dead also one large
pizza with fennel sausage brick oven
otherwise
Sauk City and skully need some gas annex
extra straight to a bowl
okay so fight to the death pizza and
gas-o-nex job oh you have 30 minutes to
meet our demands
after that we paintball a hostage every
15 minutes got yourself a deal Gruber
get us those demands we'll be waiting
[Laughter]
[Music]
sorry Scully we only had two uniforms
it's okay for some reason all the fries
and gravy and cheese them sup my tummy
[Music]
you Hungry Hungry Hippos ate my ice
cream why was this in your trash and who
throws away a spoon it's the easiest
utensil to clean I don't even think it's
ice cream it's probably medicine you
know I'm on lots of medicines Rosa I'm
sick all over this is ice cream and I'm
gonna prove it Sarge no it's been in
their mouths well I guess your little
investigations hit a dead end
I'll be back Tillman not a problem I
hate moving
let it go hey dum-dums ice cream Moose
Tracks ice cream
how do you know yep it's definitely ice
cream no word they're going down so
whoever used this spoon their body aim
right okay let's say it is ice cream but
I didn't need it I couldn't I'm lactose
intolerant
me too I'm super lactose in color you're
lying
have you ever seen us eat dairy you know
no one can bear to watch you eat check
and check we're here to apologize
can't prove you took my Moose Tracks so
I should have yelled at you I'm
impressed
it takes a big person to admit when
they're being a total dum-dum we want to
make it up to you
we got your pizza only one pizza for
both of us oh my god that was an obvious
setup you morons you're eating cheese
you're lying about being lactose
intolerant no we want some things are
just delicious enough to suffer the
consequences I'm diabetic but I still
eat sugar out the bag well just admit
you took my Moose Tracks admit admit it
yeah we ate it and we're eating your
pizza
so who's the [ __ ] now
oops dummy oh yeah coming they admitted
it that's the victory right no Terry
there are no winners here
[Laughter]
thanks for taking us to lunch Jake of
course get whatever you want
oh man how are you eight I guess I'll
just have a cheeseburger deluxe couples
license apply maybe an egg cream okay
Anna waffle where's his car I'm taking
you guys off your drug case of course
you are Jake said you didn't believe in
us what he didn't believe in you either
he was just pumping you up with lie so
you could work his case Jake is this
true I just thought you know the two of
you might be better off mousing around
the old house oh I get it
just because I got my finger stuck in a
glue trap once I'm a mouse I got to
cheese out by the way oh my god
according to a recent study the physical
act of smiling can improve your mood I
suggest we give it a shot hmm now y'all
try big smiles bigger bigger great now
we just have to stay like this for the
next two hours can you feel it
looking I don't have any enamel on my
teeth so the cold air is excruciating
maybe you brushed your teeth once in a
while this wouldn't be a problem
I do brush my teeth they're decaying
from acid reflux
you're birthing yourself for like a
you're not Australian Gina gets tough
dude wrong go okay so seriously too much
exposure to air and they will turn to
dust this isn't working out as well as
I'd hoped
time for the next level forced laughing
type 3 and type 9 and 12 and 13 those
are all the diabetes is I have it's true
what they say
nightshift makes for strange bedfellows
and your dreams perv
attention squad pretty dainty way to
make an announcement it's a workplace I
wanted to be respectful well as someone
at a high risk for a spook related death
thank you she's here she's here Cindy
Schatz is here what do I do
my face is so bad and my mouth is so dry
hey calm down
remember be direct women don't like to
play a lot of games I think we got a
start simpler okay Scully smile at her
don't fart he knows not to oh you're
writing that down this is good stuff
what else you that don't talk about your
foot fungus don't talk about your eye
fungus let's just say fungus is off the
table
Oh No see you just wrote the word fungus
down and I feel like we're barreling
towards a misunderstanding draw a circle
around it and then put a line through it
there you go believe in yourself be
confident you're a sweet guy with a big
heart it's the size of a giraffe's it
pushes on my other organs okay you got
this don't talk about the draft part all
right we're on Gina's mobile should I
place this moonless Jupiter I pity the
child who lies beneath this solar system
hey captain something's going on with
this heist you tell us everything you
know and we'll tell you everything we
know my brother knows ah joke's on you
we don't know anything well good David
wait why are you sweating I'm not sweaty
I've had enough heart attacks to know
what sweating looks like not sweat Oh
nine hours and 55 minutes is it feel
like I just sat down I have no feeling
down here whatsoever I haven't in years
I'm doing great too this has been a
piece of cake oh but crap my crap that
sounds painful but you could use some
electrolytes give me that that's mine
come get it you'll never catch me
oh won't I
[Music]
Oh cramp over those airships huh you
thought I couldn't wait what are you
doing you thought we were done just
because our shift was over
amateur oh so you want to take this into
overtime fine
I got no place to be either do I I never
do and it's agreed the games continue
how long have you been sitting my bus
lost track of time
coming up on 32 hours oh I miss the
little things
showers feeling my feet standing I miss
my home chair you miss a chair I just
want to walk up to the hotdog stand out
front and get a fresh wiener oh man
why'd you say that nobody want one see
you should go get one oh and let you win
you're just trying to get us to stand up
no we should all go get one get our
chairs she's right
feel the thing holding us back a society
[Applause]
[Music]
no money - you left the chair I'm sorry
man
no it was my time
sorry time - we've been through hell
together
and always gen together
major debt score doubts
you